when i was young  something happened to me  stop saying that daddy  who are you talking to  gabriel  is he your imaginary friend  whatever you went through before you  joined our family it hurt you in a way  that i can't even imagine  you created him  what's going on  so that you could survive  i wanted to do something that was a bit  different but yet hack back to my roots  you got to take chances if you don't you  end up making the same old thing again  and again and again  i think audience is our star for  something that's new and different  [Applause]  we're gonna turn back the hands of time  close your eyes  he's there too  who is  gabriel  who is gabriel  i'm the only one that can see him  that's him  he wants to talk to you  [Applause]  malignant  ritadar september 10th  [Music]  you